they add up to 90 supplementary means
they add up to 180
but in precalculus we do a lot of our
work in radians so when we think of
adding up to 90 we're thinking of adding
up to PI over 2 when we think of 180 we
think about adding up to PI radians so
let's do some examples and I'll show you
how to solve these problems see you want
to find the complement of PI over 6 PI
over 6 so what you would do is you would
take PI over 2 which remember is 90
degrees minus PI over 6 and that's going
to give you your complement of course we
have to get common denominators so I'm
going to multiply this by 3 over 3 so
that gives you 3 PI over 6 minus 1 PI
over 6 which equals 2 PI over 6 which we
can reduce to PI over 3
ok so PI over 3 would be the complement
to PI over 6 meaning these two are going
to add up to 90 degrees PI over 2 so
that's your complement now if you want
to solve for the supplement what you're
going to do is going to take PI minus
the angle PI over 6 is the one we're
working with again we have to get common
denominators so we're going to multiply
by 6 over 6 so this is 6 PI minus 1 PI
all over 6 which gives us 5 PI over 6
that'll be our supplement so supplement
complement ok so they add up to 90 or
the two angles add up to 180 degrees now
sometimes when you're doing this problem
you'll come across an example where
there isn't a complement or there is not
a supplement and so I'll show you an
example of that so say for example you
had let's just do this one over here
let's say that your angle is 3 PI over 4
okay so if we try to do PI over 2 minus
3 PI over 4 you might not notice this
initially but when we get common
denominators
okay multiply by 2 over 2 we get
two pi over 4 minus 3 PI over 4 equals a
negative PI over 4 ok so see how came it
to a negative angle so what that means
is that there's no complement ok because
this angle already exceeds 90 degrees or
PI over 2 radians so no complement if we
want to find the supplement same idea we
do PI minus 3 PI over 4 you want to get
common denominator so I'm gonna multiply
by 4 over 4 so that comes out to 1 PI
over 4 this is positive so there is a
supplement PI over 4 so this has been a
little bit about how to find complements
and supplements working with the Radian
angle measurements and you can see
sometimes you don't get a complement or
you might not get a supplement if it
turns out to be negative but again the
key is just to use PI over 2 minus the
angle or PI minus the angle and you've
got it I'll see you in the next video